this is manner
she's a young French volunteer and she's
in Budapest to begin a placement with
the Danube transnational program doing
charitable work in the region and these
young people are helping to restore
historic buildings damaged by
earthquakes in north Chea central italy
both these programs are part of the new
European solidarity Corps which brings
together young volunteers participating
in activities across the EU to help
people and communities what we want is
additional voluntary solidarity
activities according to climate change
in other parts of environmental
activities doing voluntary work with
children with elderly people other
solidarity core activities include
education health and working with
migrants and asylum seekers with
priority given to charitable work
Parliament has taken the first steps in
setting up the Corps with a proposed
budget of 375 million euros from 2018 to
2020 and those volunteers take part in
projects which benefit people they'll
gain vital life skills and knowledge for
their own futures I think we all know
that young people are willing to
contribute to the European project cost
build up their own future to be in
contact with other people society and
life a little bit better so if you're
aged between 17 and 30 I would like to
help make your society a little better
you can register now with the European
solidarity Corps